bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 22 octobre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de votre actualité locale concours de la
maison économe à l' agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat de saint quentin
en yvelines a annoncé les vainqueurs de
cette 9e édition nous avons rencontré
des participants trappistes et leurs
maisons dites passives
il est sorti pour les vacances de la
toussaint la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet se met à l'heure du far west
atelier déguisements et animations tout
est fait pour les petits cow-boys et les
petits indiens et ce week-end n'oubliez
pas de régler vos montrer vos réveils
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche nous
passerons à l'heure d'hiver il faudra
reculer l'éguille de sa montre d'une
heure pour leur faire passer de trois à
deux heures du matin une habitude qui ne
fait pas l'unanimité pour reparler avec
nous ce soir
eléonore gabarain présidente de
l'association contre l'heure d'été
double ans et nous ouvrons ce journal
avec un mot de politique david douillet
était à saint germain en laye ce matin
le républicain à distribuer à cette
occasion des tracts devant la gare du
rer a pour soutenir la campagne de
valérie pécresse dans le cadre des
régionales
une élection qui je vous le rappelle est
programmée les 6 et 13 décembre une
conférence d'une heure a ensuite été
organisée sur le thème des transports
david douillet a présenté à cette
occasion les grands chantiers de la
droite sur cette problématique le député
de la 12e circonscription des yvelines
était au micro dé michael almy le rôle
des plus belles compositions c'est 2
d'amener mille bus dans cette grande
couronne et d'améliorer les parkings de
les agrandir été créé pour que les
personnes qui vivent en grande couronne
puisse avoir aussi parce qu'ils payent
des impôts - la région mais n'en ont pas
le retour à travers les transports donc
que puissent profiter des transports
pleinement autant que les urbains et la
deuxième proposition s'il fallait en
retenir deux j'hésite encore c'est aussi
le changement de toutes les rames d'ici
2020 heures de train transilien
david douillet qui est d'ailleurs ce
soir sur la commune de montigny le
bretonneux afin de parler aux électeurs
de la campagne des régionales des
républicains et régionales toujours le
ps s'engage pour le commissariat
d'elancourt vous voyez à l'image d'aller
voir ce sont les plans du projet initial
de 2006 alors que bernard cazeneuve a
donné le coup d'envoi de la construction
du nouveau commissariat d'elancourt et
débloqué cent mille euros pour réaliser
les études de préfiguration du chantier
où les investissements nécessaires sont
évalués à environ cent mille euros
les candidats du parti socialiste
emmenée par claude bartolone ont affirmé
leur engagement pour ce projet afin que
la région continue à le soutenir et
participer à ce financement aux côtés de
l'état
un mode environnement à présent l'agencé
locale de l'énergie et du climat de
saint quentin en yvelines annoncé ce
mois ci les vainqueurs de la 9e édition
du concours maisons économes un concours
récompensant les changements de
comportement vis-à-vis de nos
habitations cette année un couple de
trappistes était candidat ils ont choisi
de faire de faire construire une maison
dite passive
explications avec mélanie poté ossature
bois planchers en béton et bardage bois
un souci d'économie mais avant tout une
volonté d'autonomie énergétique
cette maison de 135 mètres carrés c'est
la réalisation d'un couple trappistes
les murs de leurs habitations font 40 cm
d'épaisseur et la maison est quasiment
hermétique leur habitation précédente
ancien énergivores a été totalement
rasée et reconstruite
il ya très peu
chauffer en quasiment en totalité par le
soleil il ya un petit apport énergétique
mais qui est extrêmement minime par
avoir une maison classique
après il ya tout ce qui va de
ventilation double flux pour qui est
obligatoire en fait pour une maison pour
une maison passive qui est complètement
hermétique il ya de la maine de laine de
verre et c'est polystyrène donc on est
on est parti sur les options notamment
écologiques que le coup derrière il nous
faisait dépasser le budget des renforts
le couple a décidé d'opter pour une
maison dite passive
un bâtiment qui en théorie n'a pas
besoin d'énergie pour se chauffer ou
très peu le 28 septembre dernier le jury
du concours maisons économes initiée sur
50 ha ennuyé par la lèque et vérifie
l'installation cette maison concourt
dans la catégorie construction
le concours maisons économes c'est la 9e
10 ans cette année
il a pour objectif de valoriser les
projets particulièrement intéressant de
territoire donc soit technique dans la
construction la rénovation qui fait
appel à des techniques assez peu
répandue encore des matériaux pas trop
utiliser
jeudi 15 octobre les candidats sont
rassemblés pour connaître les résultats
sur les sept candidatures retenues par
le jury trois concours et dans la
catégorie construction et c'est la
maison trappistes qui est désignée
gagnante le jury récompense ont ainsi
les performances de la maison opération
propreté aujourd'hui à lille de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines les
salariés de suzuki france ont participé
à une opération de nettoyage dans le
cadre d'une campagne mondiale a
baptisées queen of the world
les employés de l'entreprise qui est
basée à trappes ont ramassés pendant
toute une matinée les détritus de l'île
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
une opération menée en concertation avec
les guides de la réserve
reportage de william l ils étaient 25 ce
jeudi à avoir répondu présent à
l'opération de nettoyage organisée par
leur entreprise
petit briefing pour les salariés de
suzuki france avant d'enfiler leurs
gants pour partir à la recherche
c'est un engagement de tout de tous les
représentants suzuki à travers le monde
de passer une journée ou une
demi-journée à faire en sorte de
nettoyer la terre pour rendre aux
espaces naturels leur environnement film
the world c'est le nom de cette
opération lancée par suzuki
aujourd'hui les employés prennent cette
demi-journée sur leur temps de travail
pour venir nettoyer le bord du lac de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est aussi un engagement d'essayer
d'avoir le minimum d'impact sur sur
l'environnement l'impact mais ça
commence aussi par la pollution donc
l'activité marine est leader dans ce
domaine là donc ça fait partie aussi de
nos dix engagements qu'on essaye de
mettre bout à bout les uns derrière les
autres qui permettrait peut-être de
faire des choses sac poubelle à la main
les employés ont arpenté les bords du
lac toute la matinée
ce lieu beaucoup d'entre le connaissent
bien et pour cause la plupart sont des
habitants de la communauté
d'agglomération
si le caisson de venir quand même
quelques fois la base de loisirs pas
très souvent joue la corde mais quand
même quelques fois et là du coup je suis
très contente de participer au nettoyage
22 d'une région que je connais quand
même bien je viens régulièrement en
week-end ici me promener effectivement
on voit qu'il ya beaucoup d'esprit
tuquoi n'en suis pas surprise durant
l'année sept personnes sont employées
pour le nettoyage et l'entretien du site
de 480 hectares d'où l'importance de ce
type d'opération dans trois semaines ce
seront les jeunes du collège des prés de
montigny le bretonneux qui prendront le
relais et ce week-end préparez-vous à
changer d'heure comme chaque année nous
passons à l'heure d'hiver à 3 heures du
matin il sera en fait deux heures nous
gagnerons donc une heure de sommeil
durant donc ce week-end pourtant cette
habitude ne fait pas forcément
l'unanimité pourront parler avec nous en
plateau eléonore gabarain présidente de
l'association contre l'heure d'été
double on soir à vous et merci à ce mal
est revenu alors je le rappelle le
changement d'heure a été mise en place
après le premier choc pétrolier en 1975
le but était alors de faire correspondre
au mieux les heures d'activités avec les
heures d'ensoleillement pour limiter
l'utilisation de l'est
les rages artificiel aujourd'hui selon
vous la drogue à bas rhin cette mesure
n'a plus lieu d'être
pourquoi et côté économie d'énergie en
fait on a certes quelques économies
d'éclairage mais qui sont en train de
diminuer à cause de l'utilisation des
lampes économes qui consomment moins à
l'heure là c'est une évidence
mathématique et mais des
surconsommations qui sont donc qui vit
qui sont encore contrer ces c'est ses
économies ils ont été évaluées depuis
longtemps il y en a côté surface et le
parc de matinée froide climatisation à
cause des soirées chaudes et aussi dans
les transports de quinon qui n'ont pas
été complètement évaluer parce que notre
association demande que les et que les
surconsommations des climatisations des
véhicules donc soit étudiée il était
probable que les véhicules consomment
davantage quand on quitte son travail au
milieu de l'après midi au moment et les
plus jeunes alors pourtant laden donc l'
agence de l'environnement et de la
maîtrise de l'énergie annonce 4 %
d'économies sur la consommation liée à
l'éclair à l'éclairage alors que les
opposants vous également raisonne sur la
consommation globale avec une économie
comprise entre 0 3 et 0 25%
comment on explique cette différence
écouter parce que l'ademe ne veut pas
prendre en compte les études fait dans
d'autres pays en allemagne dès la
première année d'application de l'heure
d'été dans ces pays on a on a évalué des
surconsommations qui était à peu près
les deux tiers des économies d'éclairage
et ensuite on a vu qu'il y avait des
donc ces surconsommations de
climatisation aux etats unis un dans
l'indiana
on a mesuré une augmentation de la
consommation des ménages de 1 % de
l'électricité mais vous dit en france je
ne sais pas pourquoi on méprise et ces
évaluations qui ont été faits par des
étais tout est très compétent alors ce
changement d'heure ne fait pas l'absolu
je ne vais pas l'unanimité au niveau des
français selon un sondage paru récemment
par opinionway et trois quarts des
français donc 73 76 % préféré rester
donc alors été ne pas passer à leurs
diverses 17% des français ils sont
favorables et 52 indique même qu'il
souhaiterait supprimer justement le
changement d'heure nous avons demandé
leur avis aux saint quentinois je vous
propose de regarder leurs témoignages
c'est positif à tout moment on peut
avoir un peu de soleil le matin
malheureusement le soir on en perd mais
ça permettra des économies d'énergie
c'est moi ça me pose pas de problème ça
décale les habitudes
alors on a plus de trop la nuit joueurs
on sait plus trop où on reste quand même
c'est désagréable moi j'aime pas je sais
pas si c'est vraiment utile c'est vrai
que les journées rallongent
raccourcissent il ya besoin de s'adapter
aussi avec la lumière du jour c'est
important mais bon est-ce que c'est
vraiment un outil je sais pas mais moi
ça me perturbe pas particulièrement chic
pour les jeunes enfants pour les rythmes
etc
ça peut être différent c'est en tout cas
c'est très perturbant pour tout le monde
voilà je vous vois pas forcément la
nécessité alors voilà justement on voit
que la majorité des gens phare qu'est
les gens interrogés sont sont plutôt
opposées ségolène royal a annoncé en
mars que le gouvernement vérifierait
l'impact sur les économie d'énergie
penser que c'est possible d'abonnés
cette habitude mais un peu de notre
association n'a pas eu connaissance des
villans nouveau qui aurait fait et donc
l'ademe une autre institut pour madame
royal et moi j'ai participé à une étude
sur les effets pervers de l'heure d'été
mais c'est pareil je n'ai pas encore eu
les résultats
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il a dit
madame royal lors d'une d'une mission
d'enquêté lévis et c'est que c'était
pratiquement impossible de revenir en
arrière dans l'état actuel des choses la
france à cause des autres pays de
l'europe qui voudraient comme donc elles
conservées l'heure d'été mais bon on ne
sait pas avec quel pays elle a ses
intérêts annuels ou ses conseillers bon
mais si l'allemagne voulait à vendre de
l'heure d'été
l'allemagne et la france entraînerait
les hôtes et d'autre part il ya un
problème avec la commission européenne
qui commandait de rapports des instituts
qui ne sont pas compétents parce que
j'ai lu attentivement les dernières
rapport ils comprennent pas bien toutes
les nuances d
leur le système des fuseaux horaires et
cetera et puis d'ailleurs il c'est avec
ça comme ils sont commises et et met
donc anglais pour les dernières rapport
il comprenait pas les français
j'ai envoyé qu'un rapport beaucoup de
documents ils n'ont visé mais d'ailleurs
écrit un livre à l'extérieur mais eux
ils n'ont lu qu'une lettre en anglais
envoyée au président obama
voilà c'est ça alors avantage de la
mariée de fâcher et j'ai voulu écrire un
livre en expliquant tous les appels
heure d'été puis avec des années de
doutes pour que parce qu'il est vécu
intéressant de manière à est-ce que et
ça puisse être plus léger pour les
poules et les lecteurs alors voilà que
vous pouvez me rappeler le titre dit
c'est au musée des erreurs l'heure d'été
donc sous tutelle est victime d'une
légende
les gens disent économie notre vie et
non vie aux éditions edilivre nacre est
bien voir si vous voulez tout savoir sur
et peut-être les erreurs ou et
changements de vent étaient n'hésitez
pas à regarder ça y est merci beaucoup
d'être venu sur notre plateau et d'avoir
répondu à notre question mais n'oubliez
pas à l'heure d'été on est quand même
obligé d'y passer ce sera ce week-end et
vous profitez peut-être des vacances de
la toussaint en ce moment alors si vous
êtes amateur de barbe à papa ou deux
manèges voici une idée de sortie qui
vous plaira certainement pour la
trentième année consécutive la fête
foraine de versailles vous accueille
ouverte de 14 heures à 20 heures chaque
jour elle restera ouverte jusqu'au 20
novembre
fanny bourdillon est allé faire le tour
des attractions pour nous
la chenille le shaker ou encore le x
factor les attractions de la foire
d'automne de versailles tourne à plein
régime à quelques mètres du château sur
le parking de la place de l'europe
cette fête populaire attire de
nombreuses familles pour les coaches
tous les passants canard ou les manèges
d'enfants pour les adolescentes et les
jeunes y
rony brauman aise on en a pour tous les
âges et tous les jours d'une fête
foraine on va dire ben pyne et il ya un
engouement des versailles et pour leur
fête foraine
ils détiennent vous voyez donc comme du
temps beaucoup de villes en pente
fait une tradition du doit perdurer la
vingtaine de manèges de cette fête
foraine peut vite devenir un budget
conséquent pour une famille mais les
plus économes pourront profiter de
nombreuses réductions le dimanche mi
novembre
c'était le dimanche 8 pour la journée à
1 euro que n'at on a énormément de monde
et puis être intéressant dit rappelant
qu'elle était pris pour redire les
habitants de versailles pour un euro le
tour de manège de la base installée
chaque automne depuis maintenant trente
ans la fête foraine est devenu une
tradition pour les uns ça y est en
parlant de vacances ou préférait
peut-être les animaux ou encore cette
fan du far west
alors prenez la direction de rambouillet
toujours pendant ses vacances
la bergerie nationale se transforme en
véritable ranch et organise pour la
cinquième année consécutive
d après midi dédié au far west alors
cowboy ou indiens il faudra choisir son
camp reportage de michael elle imite
euros elodie moines la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet prend des airs
de far west pendant les vacances
scolaires pour la cinquième année
consécutive des animations autour des
cowboys et des indiens sont programmées
tous les jours de 14 heures à 18 heures
dépaysement garanti qu envoyé en dire en
fait ces deux camps le corps des indiens
et le camp des cowboys locaux des
indiens on peut trouver du tir à l'arc
justement des ateliers créatifs pour
fabriquer ses armes et son décaissement
des balades à poney et à dos d'âne en
fait comme l'existence d'un comme petit
tonnerre est du côté des cowboys en fait
c'est chercher des pépites d'or
s'entraîner au lancer de faire au jeu du
lasso s'entraîner son cheval mécanique
aussi et s'entraîner au tir à cal tir à
la carabine
le clou du spectacle la traditionnelle
attaque de diligence six animateurs
déguisés aux couleurs des westerns
organise un combat sans merci entre les
peaux rouges et les visages pâles
chef des indiens on a fait une tirade à
caen nous avons à gagner et après on
attention et le spectacle c'est génial
ce spectacle c'est génial après les
animations qui a aux alentours c'est top
les enfants il peut le faire s'ils
veulent ça tourne beaucoup c'est top je
sais que quelque chose de simple mais ça
plaît aux enfants
donc c'est c'est très plaisant et en
plus si on peut on peut se costumer le
tarif pour l'après midi de 6 euros pour
les adultes et de 4 euros pour les
enfants l'événement attire chaque année
plus de 8 mille curieux
elle a été élu meilleur ouvrier de
france la plus haute distinction pour un
artisan sa spécialité c'est la
restauration de tapisseries sylvie joly
est originaire de plaisir et pratique
cet art de grande pureté
cet art de grande précision pardon
sephora a la manie et elodie mois nous
rencontrer voici son portrait sylvie
joly a poussé les portes du mobilier
national pour la première fois en 1999
après quatre ans de formation dans cette
institution
anciennement garde-meuble de la couronne
cette plaisir oise devient technicienne
d'art son métier restaurer les
tapisseries propriété de l'état qui
meublent les grandes institutions
françaises telles que l'elysée les
ambassades à l'étranger tapisserie qui
peuvent également faire l'objet de prêts
pour les expositions sur une tapisserie
on peut intervenir en plaçant une toile
en fait une fine toile de coton
souleuvre qui va nous servir de support
qui vise plus à stopper la dégradation
des matériaux le fait qu'on place cette
toile qui est légèrement colorée aide
en fait avec le recul de l'oeil vous ne
voyez presque pu voyaient presque plus
l'usure l'idée c'est d'intervenir
légèrement mais de faire juste ce qu'il
faut pour que l'on s'attarde pas sur
l'usure et qu'on garde la patine de
l'oeuvre originaire d'une famille de
couturière sylvie joly a toujours le
goût du dépassement
c'est pourquoi elle s'inscrit en 2013 au
concours d'excellence de meilleur
ouvrier de france
après la réussite de l'épreuve
qualificative en 2014
elle constitue son dossier de constat
d'état du neuf représentants des lacunes
pour concourir à l'épreuve finale
celui-ci validé par le jury elle dispose
de trois mois et 200 heures pour
restaurer sa tapisserie
le projet est un succès
sylvie joly et ça crie mof à l'été 2015
je vais surtout fait pour moi c'était
important pour moi de dépasser mes
limites et de voir où j'en étais là on
est vraiment jugé sur nous mêmes on peut
repousser les limites
ce qui est aussi l'intérêt de ce
concours c'est fine c'est toute
l'humilité qui se cache derrière c'est
un des meilleurs ouvriers de france le
vrai titre
c'est à dire qu' il n'y a pas qu'un il
n'y a pas qu'une peau qu'un poste ya pas
qu une personne qui peut y aurait eu le
réussir sylvie joly a reçu sa médaille
de meilleur ouvrier de france dans le
grand amphithéâtre de la sorbonne en
présence d 275 autres lauréats avant
d'être reçu par la suite par le
président de la république à l'elysée et
nous parlons à présent de sport
aujourd'hui se clôturer la 12e édition
de sport en fille cet événement organisé
par le cros siffle comité régional
olympique et sportif d'île de france
permet à des jeunes filles issues de
quartiers prioritaires de pratiquer des
activités sportif l'objectif est de
promouvoir le sport féminin d'agir
contre les inégalités et de développer
la vie associative et sportive
ces jeunes filles ont donc pu profiter
du 20 octobre jusqu'à aujourd'hui de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines qui est partenaire de
l'opération
écoutez les précisions 2 1 sans couteau
recueilli par william l
on vise un objectif de 100 jeunes filles
par jour donc on avait quatre jours
jusqu'à présent toujours cette année
mais on va atteindre les 300 320 je
crois cette année alors 100 jeunes
filles de 14 à 17 ans puisqu'on sait que
non ces quartiers là c'est pas forcément
évident pour les jeunes filles de
pratiquer une activité sportive de se
mettre en tenue de sport de ce mix et
avec les garçons donc c'est vraiment une
volonté du cros ziff de permettre à ces
jeunes filles de s'épanouir de décor aux
activités sans honte sans peur du regard
des autres
les filles se motiver ya toujours des
activités sportives individuelles
collectives des sports de ballon des
sports de combat des sports d'eau etc
et comme chaque jeudi vous n'avez
maintenant l'habitude on retrouve
michael et les 1000 euros pour la
chronique sport bon samuel montsort
florennes nous débutons cette chronique
sport part du handball féminin un choc
est programmée ce week-end à 50 ans
nîmes avec le match
montigny-le-bretonneux contre
rochechouart une équipe qui vise
clairement la montée la rencontre est
programmée au gymnase alain colas à
montigny ce samedi à 20h30 pour nous
parler de cet événement nous recevons
sur ce plateau
mais il ya l'étrange bonsoir ça alors
est ce que ce match contre rochechouart
va être très compliqué pour montigny un
match assez compliqué une équipe qui
vise la montée cas des très bonnes
recrues avec une arrière qui marque une
dizaine de buts un match donc ça
s'annonce compliqué face à une équipe
que vous connaissez bien alors pas du
tout c'est la première fois que tu me
contre elle donc on sait pas trop ce
qu'elles valent mise à part les
résultats qu'elles ont eues au dernier
match
vous aimez jouer en vitesse avec des
redoublements de passes est ce que ce
sera les recettes pour emporter la
victoire va falloir qu'on joue notre jeu
donc à vite une bonne défense qu'on ne
parle pas trop de ballons on va tout
donner pour gagner après on sait que ça
va être compliqué mais on va tout faire
pour réussir
donc vous êtes monté cette année en
nationale une féminine est-ce que le
niveau est si compliqué que ça c'est sûr
qu'il ya un gros palier entre la
nationale 2 enfin la hénin c'est quelque
chose qui est assez compliqué il ya des
choses qui commencent à devenir pro qui
sont payés donc c'est pas du tout pareil
que la nationale 2 cacv assez forte
comme nationale vous avez bien débuté le
championnat avec deux victoires en trois
matchs depuis deux semaines vous marquez
un petit peu le pas avec notamment deux
défaites comment l'expliquez vous on a
eu un calendrier assez dedans on a
rencontré deux équipes qui étaient
bataille s'annonçait bat a beau jouer le
maintien après là on a trois matches qui
s'annoncent très compliquées dans le
match de la semaine dernière avec des
équipes qui visent la
à monter on sait que c'est compliqué on
les reçoit à domicile c'est une chance
pour nous pour gagner c'est tout faire
pour réussir il ya aussi une absence
aussi qui compte énormément en ce moment
à montigny c'est l'absence de carole
mythes et les heures qui est parti en
allemagne qui ne jouera plus cette
saison pour montigny est ce que c'est
vraiment une grosse perte pour l'équipe
le côté droit c'est un côté très fort
dans notre équipe on compte des coûts
sur elle notamment dans les moments de
difficulté à savait prendre le jeu à son
compte
carole c'est une grosse perte et puis
fanny on a hâte de la retrouver dans
quinze jours fanny jean baptiste qui
blesse c'est en sombrant et le maintien
restera la priorité du club cette saison
une priorité si on peut faire un peu
mieux tant mieux mais le maintien c'est
vraiment la plus grosse des priorités et
vous pensez que c'est jouable
toute ma jeunesse c'est tout c'est
toutes ces joueuses qui manquent
qui est qui qui ne sont plus dans
l'équipe du coup actuellement est ce que
c'est jouable quand même parce que
chaque point sera important cette année
la saison va être longue tous les points
sont bons à prendre
il ya eu des petites modifications au
niveau des postes pour cette joueuse
pour pallier les absences et oran on a
un début de championnat et dans pareil
pour la fin du championnat on va tout
faire pour gagner pour le maintien pense
que c'est possible
merci à vous d'être placé sur ce plateau
je le rappelle le match entre mon team
retenu rochechouart est programmée ce
samedi à 20h30 au gymnase alain colas a
menti ont continué à parler de handball
d'auchel tentera de remporter son
premier match de saison ce week-end
promu cette saison en nationale 2 le
chesnay avait perdu toutes ses
rencontres depuis le début de la saison
l'hémorragie s'est arrêté le week-end
dernier avec un match nul contre torcy
et chesnaysiens devront également
réalisé un gros match pour venir à bout
de suivi sur loire ce week end
chaque point est important pour la lutte
pour le maintien pour les encourager la
rencontre est programmée ce samedi à 20
heures au gymnase nouvelle france mais
on parle football à présent déjà on
jouera le 6e tour de la coupe de france
ce week-end cinq équipes illinois sont
encore en lice dans cette prestigieuse
compétition verset jouera notamment
grigny ce dimanche mais si vous voulez
rester dans le département florane je
vous conseille d'aller voir le match
entre chatou qui évolue en dhr et
viry-châtillon une équipe de cfa la
rencontre se jouera au stade final terry
dimanche à 14h30 sur le papier cette
rencontre paraît déséquilibré mais la
magie de la coupe de france peut opérer
à tout moment florennes et enfin de la
paix ton pour terminer votre chronique
telle la célèbre la célèbre compétition
la boule élan courtoise et organiser ce
mange de 14 heures à 18 heures au parc
des sports guy boniface à elancourt plus
d'une centaine de participants sont
attendus pour la manifestation le niveau
doit être relevé
les meilleurs tireurs et pointeurs du
département seront présents
je pense que c'est un rendez vous que
vous n'allez pas manquer floral
évidemment je suis amatrice de béton on
vous retrouve demain dans le on va
parler de la bergerie nationale 2 de
rambouillet qui organise justement des
rencontres far west et nous allons
également parlé de bob castiel un
yvelinois qui a sorti un nouvel album et
il a fait partie de l'équipe des grosses
têtes pendant 27 ans quel programme nous
ne manquerons pas oui et justement c'est
à la fin de cette édition demain vous
retrouver wilfried est enrichie pour le
vendredi c'est lui qui présentera
l'édition du cdh frites le journal quant
à moi je vous retrouve lundi pour une
nouvelle édition de cette le journal en
direct à 18h je vous souhaite donc un
bon week-end une bonne soirée et
peut-être aussi des bonnes vacances
au revoir